it doesn't have to be perfect one of the
biggest lessons that I learned early on
in my business career with my first
companies that it doesn't have to be
perfect where we wanted to be perfect
where we wanted it to have the perfect
plan and spend so much time working on
the perfect plan before ever actually
releasing it out that we ended up losing
a 42 million dollar sale and that still
burns me today but it was a good lesson
how I applied it to my book is we
launched the book website you know we
launched it up it's it's it's pretty
good if you compare it to most authors
and what they do for their pre launch
campaigns and pre launch books it's
pretty good but it's not perfect I think
it's way better than most but it's still
not perfect in my eyes is it can always
be better that's the thing with with
someone's perfectionist like I'm a
recovering perfectionist it could always
be better there's always something to
improve on and it's embracing that
embracing the desire to get better and
to improve with releasing stuff because
if all you do is try to get better and
get better and get better never release
anything you're never making money
you're never getting feedback in what
you think may work may not actually work
and you got to test it out test those
assumptions and so we put up the page
and it's really good but it could be
better you know there's a lot of
placeholders right now that show video
coming soon right I haven't recorded
those videos I need to do that soon the
page loaded really slowly because we
were just throwing tons of high res
pictures at it and we're just so worried
about getting the website up that it
loaded slowly we got that feedback from
people we now improved it it's a lot
faster to load some of the bonus
packages were confusing for some people
they didn't know what everything meant
it was just like a one-liner and so
we're working on making that more clear
easy to understand more visual it takes
some time it's still not up yet we're
working on it's coming so all this stuff
is still coming but it's already good
enough right it is good enough to push
out and we want to make it better so
don't let that perfectionist side of you
prevent you from releasing something
because it's never going to be perfect
will be it's always room for improvement
now on top of sharing something about
the book of rent at the top and then
answering your questions I thought it'd
be also fun to update you on the goal of
how we're doing on selling the books the
pre-sale targeted 3,000 books and
apparently that's what you need to get
on the bestseller list still not a
guaranteed spot so it's great to have
more than that but the that was the
initial presale goal we are at what are
we at 39 39 I have a 3000 so that's what
just over one percent we got a lot of
work to do and I started adding the
counter at the top of the website and
the counter shows you our goal and then
how many we've sold so far as well as
seeing some thinking messages to some of
the people who bought the books recently
and so I thought it'd be cool to kind of
update you as well as how many books
were selling on a regular basis how many
books we sell each week I don't know the
author's never share this stuff so what
is the best seller what do you need to
get to make the best seller list and
hopefully you know hopefully we get
enough to really get there and I thought
that by sharing that again the whole
point of this video series is to give
you guys kind of behind the scenes and
what it takes to get a book with a major
publisher off the ground and so they may
hate me for this i don't know what
they've seen it yet but but i want to
keep it and hopefully give you guys an
honest update on how well the book is
doing and hopefully maybe that inspires
you to want to help out a little bit
more as well all right let's get to the
questions first up is a no super excited
about reading your book and discovering
my one word i'm one of the many people
who don't really know what they're about
and who they are and i believe your book
will help me figure things out like your
videos have already helped me in many
ways and after reading this I know that
Zino has already purchased the book
thank you so much saying that means a
lot to me you you got a random shadow
two and one of the other videos so stay
tuned for that I think the book will
definitely help I think it helps you
with that that self-awareness to know
what it is that you staying for and then
start to live a life on purpose
initially my intent was just for
entrepreneurs but I actually gave the
pre version of the book out the twice as
long version of the book out to was the
20 people 30 people i don't remember now
and half of them were not entrepreneurs
and they loved it which was super
interesting i know it will do well with
entrepreneurs it just will but for the
non entrepreneurs it was super
interesting to see how much value they
got out of it
and how much they see it applying to
their life and their career so they know
I'm super excited I know you watch a lot
of the videos that you've comments
everywhere really appreciate that and
I'm excited to see after you go through
the exercises and read the book what you
learn from it because i'm i'm excited
i'm excited i think you know come with
something special next up is lee you're
making a real difference in people's
lives including my own and I appreciate
all the hard work you give and your team
of believe nation working towards a
cause Thank You Lee that really means a
lot to me thank you for also
acknowledging amazon UK i found the link
on that website selling your book your
one word it happens to be a deluxe
edition i just want to know this is the
full version of your book before i buy
so yes in terms of the book there's
going to be three options is a hardcover
version which is already available for
pre-order there is the audio version
which is not available yet and i'm so
upset at the guys in charge of the audio
sales and i still have an update but as
soon as i do i will for you guys so i
know a lot of you want the audio version
so it's coming for the e-book there's
the regular version and a deluxe version
depending on the on the retailer i guess
you're buying from the deluxe version
has has my commentary in there i have
some videos in there so just like a
bunch of bonuses that are worked in
within the e-book itself compared to not
having it so some place you get an
options and places you don't but that is
the book it'll be the full book as well
if you buy it you qualify for the
bonuses as well you qualify for all the
free downloads you qualify for the
random shout outs all of that stuff all
qualifies if you want the extra packages
the 1025 you know 110 25 what is it 10
let me look at what are the bonus
packages I really should know this but
this is this is legit this is how we run
things here 1025 100 and 500 that is
only for the hardcover version and then
allows you to gift it to other people as
well so yes and if anybody's having
trouble with international orders please
let me know so I can contact my
publisher and say hey we've got to get
up on these places next up new future
builder what is the greatest thing
you've learned in those in-person
meetings with your supporters BTW a 347
BTW a 347 that's crazy that's legit
that's almost every day for a year new
future builder I love it spreading the
energy
that's an interesting question I would
maybe divide us in the two categories
two camps I know the questions about
supporters so if I'm thinking about
people i meet when i go traveling when i
go to sage summit when i visit different
cities and I meet up with people the
greatest single thing that I learned is
that it's having a real impact on
people's lives I mean I see it in the
comments I love it I love seeing that
from you guys that I've read it and it
fills me every day but I'm still just
speaking to a camera right and when I
meet somebody in person and they tell
you how much the videos have helped them
in some cases I'm the only person who
believes in them in their life and their
environment and then seeing how much of
a change that they make because they've
watched the videos consistently that
means something to me like it brings a
lot of value and meaning to my work and
hopefully whatever you're doing you have
customers who are feeling the same way
that you have touched them some way not
just solve the problem but help them
become better human beings that like
face-to-face storytelling is super
valuable for me you know people
sometimes drive hours to come out and
meet me because I only lend one city
that's first of all in honor that people
would spend two hours driving in to come
and meet me but then hearing their story
and knowing how much it touched them
just gives me at that extra motivation
to want to to do more in terms of
reading the book when I was writing it I
also interviewed people who are at
different stages of building the company
so from a half a million dollars to sort
of fifty thousand dollars to half a
million dollars to 1 million dollars of
5 million dollars 150 million dollars in
revenue and learning that they had all
built their business around their one
word and nobody had a blueprint to do it
nobody had a roadmap they just kind of
figured it out as they went and I wanted
to learn from them for me for my
business because I had had some success
but I don't have 150 million dollar
success so I can learn a lot from those
guys on how to do it and also how to
better tell the story and other
resources and guidelines to be able to
make it easier for the next person right
because I just doubled my way through
finding my one word and applying to my
business we're here was something that
now is replicated like you guys can do
it a lot faster than i did it because
now this is the blueprint this is what i
wish i had when i first started but it
didn't exist and for these other guys
who didn't exist either and so it is
exciting to i'm so excited to see the
business come out of this and how
quickly they take off after using it so
yeah just just meeting those
entrepreneurs and realism that nobody
had a blueprint they were just all
trying to figure out how to use our one
word to guide their business and that
led to a lot of excitement for me
because this was this is now the
blueprint is now the plan that anybody
can follow to help build their business
up and have massive success next up
Simeon thank you very much for including
my comment Evan i pre-ordered the book
sent the receipt and can't wait to start
reading it love that bro thank you I'm
based in Birmingham united kingdom so
basically in UK amazon delivers the book
awesome great i love that i came through
in the international orders for those of
you guys who are also in other countries
please let me know if the link is
working and you're getting results I
have one question really want to ask you
is there a moment in G entrepreneurship
where you can say is it too early what I
mean by the fact is that at any moment
I'm really passionate and what I'm doing
really motivated to do my work educate
myself and so on ready to talk to
customers but it is there a chance to be
too early probably need to finish
University first I gained experience
from working as an employee for a couple
years and so on I'm pretty sure you're
going to say that as i'm feeling the
moment that's the right time when i'm
curious what do you think thank you very
much awesome Evan all caps cool that's a
great question I think you know with
business it's about providing value you
know one of the most important rules and
businesses if you provide value you will
have a successful company so then it
becomes can you provide value are you
too soon too early in your development
to we would provide that value right if
you are trying to be a speaker as an
example you have to have a message you
have to be comfortable in front of the
camera you have to be comfortable on
stage and so you will have to start at a
ymca at your kids high school you know
whatever it is to get the practice and
experience because you're not going to
you're not going to get hired and get
paid you know five six figures to go
speak it's on some tour because you
can't provide that value yet right so I
don't know what you're trying to do but
can you provide enough value to somebody
and if not then you need to go learn you
got to work what I would suggest though
is a lot of people underestimate the
value that they can't provide a lot of
people beat themselves down a lot of
people don't believe in themselves
enough where they can provide a lot of
value they just don't think they can and
so because they don't think the cannons
then they don't wear what I would incur
you do is whatever your idea is to start
on the side and see can you get some
traction and if you're at the start
unsure you can go ask for help instead
of asking for our sale you can ask your
feedback and if people like it you know
they may order from you you may have a
sale or they'll give you guidance and
direction how to go at the same time get
a job and work find someone in the
industry that you want a model company
ten employees are lasted you look up to
it say I want to be like them in a
couple years then go work for them and
learn the ropes I would be doing both at
the same time I love people may have a
huge ego thing to the best at everything
and then they go out and and you know
the market hits him in the face because
they can't provide enough value but I
think more people just don't think they
can provide enough value underestimate
themselves constantly under value
themselves constantly and never take any
kind of shot I would say start now start
something on the side get some feedback
start building it up and continue to
work to learn to get the resources
experience ideas connections to help you
build what you want to build next up is
Antoine thank you very much range my
question everyone really appreciate it
if you do a launch party or whatever on
december six count on me to drop by TDS
I don't know if I'm gonna do the launch
party I don't know how you know I might
do a live stream i might do a physical
event i think so many people watching
are not here in Toronto with me so a
local event may not be great I might do
an online stream maybe have some guests
come on I don't know I haven't figured
out I'm up with two ideas what do you
guys think I should do as a launch party
leaving the comments below I really
appreciate the feedback because I saw
some time to figure that out but if I'm
bringing other people on it's going to
be a longer thing that I need to start
planning relatively seem to get it ready
for you guys next step Syed I've been
congrats in your book will buy one thank
you man really appreciate that please
answer my question how is having a goal
of oil in five languages do you think
that can be a goal or something sure can
be a goal it's not even that difficult
to gold tons of people have learned five
languages I think more importantly is
why why is that interesting to you
what's your why just having a goal
without enjoying the process will will
be failure like it can't just be I want
to check this thing off my list you have
to enjoy learning the languages you have
to have a reason to do it it's got to be
something that you really like if you
don't then there's no point I don't care
about checking out the box and say I'm
an author
I have a book I don't care I don't need
that I wanted to write a book to spread
the message us in the book I could do it
on my youtube channel but I felt this
method of using a written book could one
help me get two more people but to what
I want to explain is just better suited
to a book then video and so that's why I
want to do it so why do you want to
write do the five language it's easy
people then way more than five languages
you got to do the work to get there but
it's definitely accomplishable if it's
just to check a box you're probably not
going to stick with it it's going to be
too hard for you if you have a deep
drive and motivation coming from
somewhere then you can and it's not up
to me like what do I think who cares
what I think what do you think it is
inspiring for you this is a goal that
you really want to do if it is and go
for and don't let anybody me included
tell you that it's a stupid idea next up
Martin I love these book episodes man
thanks Martin when I started this off it
was just an experiment and maybe a
lesson for you guys want to show people
the behind the scenes a creation I did
60 episodes of this every week it's over
a year represents before I even said
what the book was about just
highlighting the process of what I was
doing behind the scenes as a way to
build momentum photo was doing but also
to educate people on the process of
writing the book with a major publisher
and how it happens so that could be
knowledge for you guys a little insight
to whatever you're making shoulder
behind the scenes people might being
sued in that and following you on your
journey your journey is value to not
just the end result but also to testing
right like I could have done three
episodes and then that I you know what I
don't want to do this this takes me the
most time of any of the videos that i
have like in terms of length of time of
me on camera it's the most time of any
of my episodes and it's probably the
least viewed if i compare it to my top
10 series you're interested series it's
it's among the least view so why keep
doing it what's the point because i like
doing it right and it comments like that
from you that you're finding value in it
and so don't be afraid to experiment
I'll do other series that I try and test
and they don't get results so i don't
really like doing them so i dropped and
so don't be afraid to keep experimenting
and trying new things in your business
because you may fall in love with
something you may build insane momentum
for you it doesn't have to be this big
thing that you start with just some
small project as a test and see if it
makes you [ __ ] a lot
next up or we eerie hey dude I'm an
upcoming film maker vlogger from New
York City you're not upcoming bro you
already are I am a filmmaker and a
vlogger from New York City period would
love the opportunity to work with you
keep up the good work by the way I don't
know what you have in mind man let me
know leaving the comments pitch me
something I come to New York yeah every
now and then my agent is in New York i
was there earlier this year if you're on
my newsletter list and for anybody if
you're on my newsletter list when i
travel to a city i leave it in my
newsletter just for people from that
city to say hey I'm coming to your city
do you want to meet up I just came back
from Chicago and met with some
entrepreneurs that were on my list super
fun one of them picked me up from the
airport another one going back to the
airport's they get some one-on-one time
for 45 minutes to talk about their
business which is also super fun instead
of just hop in a cab or taking an uber
so for all of you guys yeah if you get
on the newsletter list and I come to
your city I'd love to meet up next up
Ricardo I would love the Italian version
anyway i pre-ordered it Mille grazie
Ricardo really appreciate it and yeah
the preorder sales will help justify
where we go with multilingual so if we
get a lot from Italy I don't did you
send in your receipt I don't recognize
the name and I don't remember anybody
from Italy ordering for those you guys
ordering make sure to send in your
receipt one you get bonuses you get a
bunch of free downloads that will help
you that come instantly that you don't
have to wait until you know december six
to come till you get a random shoutout
so you get entered into a draw where
every video i'm making i give a shout
out to people who have bought the book
and so you get a you know quick quick
hit on the channel but also it helps us
identify where the numbers are coming
from so when i say sold 39 maybe i sold
way more you just guys haven't let me
know and then for multilingual for
buying books in a certain area you know
if we get a lot of orders from
California than the California books
stores bookstores will order more
instead of just ordering one copy they
may order 10 or 20 or 30 so it makes a
difference for me to show them hey we're
getting a lot of orders here so if you
bought the book make sure to send in a
receipt too next up Natalie everyone
have you thought about having your
teammates provide some comments from
behind the scenes we find that helpful
inspiring as well glad I can bring your
heart
or you make me want to be a youtuber for
value not money really appreciate that
Natalie I'm open to ideas you have like
this whole video series is the behind
the scenes of me explaining what
happened I don't know if you guys want
me to have my agent come on with me and
talk about the process or my publisher
come on talk about the process maybe
maybe as part of like a launch video I
have them come on and give some feedback
and advice I'm open like let me know
what you want to see if it's doable and
fun then I'll try it out next up Gemma
Doyle official haven't I heard you
mention what's your one word at the
music videos and honestly never made me
think about the book I didn't even know
you had a book yet i watch your videos
almost every day probably at least once
a day I love your channel and your
family are such good people but I wanted
to share with you and let you know this
in response to what you're saying about
marketing / selling from this video's
perhaps you can consider marketing /
making people even more aware of your
products love and best wishes Gemma
really appreciate that I did talk about
that in advance of everything else is
happening with the book so the first
thing I did was just mention believe or
whatever your one word is as a test like
I like it it kind of sticks with me I
like doing it I could have done a couple
of times again I'm not sure about that
there's more coming with the book i'm
doing the random shout outs at the end
of the book it's in the description so I
random chance any of the videos they'll
be more again it's not I don't want it
to be too heavy-handed there'll be some
specific videos just on the book and
some of the concepts in the book so if
your regular fan you will know about the
book and the opportunities but you won't
feel like it's over the top and just a
commercial every time because because my
main goal is impact it doesn't help me
to just pound the book and then you guys
all leave because then I'm not having an
impact sure maybe I sell some extra
books but I'm in it for the long term
and I want to be able to provide value
forever it's great feedback I sooo
appreciate it i know it's coming from a
massive place of love and you want me to
have more success in in selling the book
so keep watching let me know what you
think over the next couple weeks see if
it feels ok and again if you guys have
feedback suggestions for how to improve
i'm always open live in the comments of
any video and we'll check it out
except tamara i love Tamara because she
ordered 10 copies of the book preorder I
love time for a lot of reasons but
that's an extra reason to love Tamra
thank you so much really appreciate that
and you got a random shoutout coming up
on one of the videos too so Tamara wrote
why aren't you making money from the
book sales and how many do you have to
sell before you start making money when
you work with a major publisher it's not
for the money so I got a I got a sizable
advance for regular author let alone a
first-time author which was great a lot
of that already went into making the
book right bringing on the team and
doing the travel and making sure that
it's a you know something that I'm
extremely proud of because much more
important than earning the paycheck is
creating something that will last
forever that I want to give the Hayden
to read through and I want my wife to
read through what my parents and my
grandkids to read through and so a lot
of that money gets burnt up pretty
quickly from there you get royalty deals
and I don't know what it is I honestly
don't like it's it's a percent if it's
one percent of two percent or whatever
it is I don't know what it is so it's
more so though that it allows me to for
future book if you're just talking money
if you do well with one book you can
sell a second book way more easily at a
much higher advance and way better deals
it allows me to have a bit greater reach
which fuels my goal of impacting a
billion entrepreneurs but then that also
opens up more speaking gigs and more
YouTube subscribers and more people
finding out about the message people may
not you know love YouTube now find out
about me and hire me to come speak at
their event or whatever it is right it
doesn't pan out in that the work that
I'm doing to promote the book generates
book sales that then gives me a huge
financial gain it's much more about the
impact like if money making money is
your only goal so i'll publish you keep
most of the revenue yourself it's not my
goal and selling a hundred thousand
books is not going to make a massive
financial difference in my life at least
in the short term but in terms of
enriching me and and knowing that i'm
hitting so many people and the message
is spreading that is
worth tons you know that's worth
billions to me so yeah hopefully answer
the question Evan looks like Manu
Ginobli this is from who's this from
Rafael Garcia I don't really know manage
you nobly I know he's a basketball
player the Spurs I think I maybe should
know more i'm not a huge basketball fan
although the Raptors are you know pretty
solid now maybe people say I look like
Nicolas Cage but you know everybody
looks like Nicolas Cage so I haven't
heard managing nobly before I've got
Nicolas Cage I got the guy from friends
David Schwimmer is that the guy from
friends I think his name is David
Schwimmer and now Manu Ginobli so
Kathleen hi Evan congrats i pre-ordered
your book Kathleen really appreciate
that again I don't remember seeing the
receipt from you guys make sure you're
saying or the seed it helps for the
numbers but it also i want to give you
guys a shadows and the bonuses because
there's a lot of value in there that you
get even just for it in one book you get
a ton of value so yeah maybe i'm just
missing the name but Kathleen I know you
and I feel like I haven't seen your name
in the order list so maybe i'm wrong but
just to double check for you guys make
sure you're sending in the receipt after
you order next up a taste of honey
you're so open with the process min you
hide the secrets and wouldn't share as
well you are not jealous but encouraging
others to right to dream to do PS what
mike is at thanks and congrats thank you
you know my goal is to help inspire
entrepreneurs ago do their thing I give
advice to guy today on YouTube who's
trying to do my channel you know he's
like I'm trying to do the same thing
you're doing do you have any advice for
me okay give me some advice so that like
you can't just do what I do it's not
going to work that you can't write my
book it's my book right you can't out
Evan Evan it's just not going to happen
just got to be the best version of you
and that's why I'm not concerned about
competition because nobody can do what I
do the way I do it and if you embrace
mean that's part of the one word concept
to as part of what's covered in the book
but if you embrace who you are then
that's your competitive advantage nobody
can nobody can reach you where most
businesses are boring and just the same
as everybody else
so that's why competition becomes hard I
want to see you guys succeed if you want
if writing the book is your thing I hope
that the video series helps you have
more success and more luck and you know
get you the deal that you want and the
impact do you want to have in terms of
the microphone I've used a few over the
years the one I have now let me load it
up h1 zoom that's what it looks like
I've been recording for 30 minutes okay
see how long it takes to do one of these
videos I'm not even done yet we should
wrap this up soon h1 zoom handy recorder
you can use it like this and it captures
the microphone if you're outside you can
put a foam thing on it to block the air
right now I'm using it as a clip I
usually use as a clip that's on my bent
in its on my shirt here so I'm assure
here that captures the audio I love it
it was recommended by my my videographer
Jason and and I he uses it and then I
said I love that I gotta buy one where
do i buy look it up on amazon i want to
say it's under 100 bucks i'm not a
hundred percent a hundred percent sure
it's under 200 for sure but i want to
say it's under 100 so go check it out
and last question again from a taste of
honey do you think self-publishing is
better than traditional publishing and
your personal experience how do you
persuade your publisher to allow you to
do it your way so two questions there
first off it depends on your goal if
making money as your goal traditional
publishing is not the way to do it if
just having a book on your bucket list
you want to check off then having a
traditional publishers not the way to do
it you could just sell publish and boom
you have it if you want to have impact
though which was my goal then that was
the only reason to go with the publisher
how do I get them to convince them to do
it my way there were battles I
documented them if you go back on the
series is show some of the battles that
I had and a compromise between both of
us to get to get a final product that
word that we love you know my hundred
percent satisfied with with every
decision was made no but it's a
fantastic book I love the book and that
that's honestly what gets me through is
like this book is going to have an
impact on a lot of people and this
little tiny change that I want to make
or they don't want to make or whatever
is not worth holding up the book because
it's pretty minor at the same time it is
as well it gives me a lot more power for
the next book to say this is exactly
what I want also I'll have gone through
it like the first time you go through a
process i'm just i'm a newbie right i'm
learning everything for the first time
in this field i feel like i can write
really well but everything around
creating and marketing the book is my
first time doing it so i'm making
mistakes I'm trying to learn i'm trying
to model success if i do it again I'll
have known the process right I've been
through it before I can get there faster
I can know where to push on some things
where I can't push in others so I guess
it just really depends on your goal if
you just want a book and you want to
make money then then self-published way
easier way more lucrative if you want to
have an impact and reach more people and
get your message out there then probably
go and try to find a traditional
publisher so there's still more
questions we're over half an hour I want
to wrap this video up my voices starting
to hurt and I have more videos to record
so thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know what you think about the
the topic don't be perfect right doesn't
have to be perfect what do you think
about that how do you apply that in your
business and if you have a question
about my book or the book writing
process leave in the comments below and
I'll do my best to include you in next
week's video thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon